[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
locales et régionales de la tnt tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité
victime de son succès la ville de
bordeaux voit les projets immobiliers se
multiplier sur son territoire une bonne
nouvelle pour l'économie locale mais
aussi des nuisances pour les habitants
reportage de tv7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest dans un instant et puis vous
découvrirez la passion étonnante d'un
habitant de la loire les briques un
retraité les collectionner les exposé
dans un musée mille briques qui sont
réunis à reportage de tl7 la télévision
de la loire enfin fleurs et verdure nous
accompagnerons en fin de journal avec en
savoie un jardin des cinq sens où 1500
variétés de plantes sont entretenus et
exposés aux visiteurs
conséquence de son attractivité la ville
de bordeaux se trouve dans l'obligation
de construire de nouveaux logements pour
répondre à la demande bien sur le
belvédère bastide diel brazza autant de
nouveaux quartiers qui voit le jour une
vitesse grand v dans la cité du vin et
si la tendance bordeaux peut sembler
bénéfique notamment pour l'économie elle
n'est pas sans effet sur la qualité de
vie des habitants un décryptage avec
baptiste monge et pour tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest
a bordeaux les bâtiments en construction
font partie du paysage ce sont quelques
6400 ménages supplémentaires qui
s'installe de part et d'autre de la
garonne chaque année pour les loger ces
chantiers se multiplient et impressionne
les riverains ça fait quand même
beaucoup et je trouve que c'est quand
même pas mal et se passer je veux dire
c'est des villes dans la ville en
quelque sorte avec ses nouveaux
quartiers mais oui c'est vrai que ça
c'est impressionnant quand j'étais très
impressionnée à partir de stalingrad
oncle après le pont de pierre toutes ces
constructions c'est trop c'est dommage
c'est dommage ça m'allait bouchant la
pollution promoteurs immobiliers
constructeur le martèle bâtir à bordeaux
est une nécessité voire une urgence au
risque de vivre une crise sociale du
logement objectivement il conviendrait
de réaliser entre 7500 et dix mille
logements neufs par an sur le territoire
construire - non car ce serait une
hérésie notamment sur le plan social il
y à des fortes demandes notamment de
logements sociaux mais construire mieux
nous sommes prêts à relever ce défi flux
migratoires étudiants diplômés en quête
d'emploi bordeaux et ses alentours pis
son attractivité mais derrière cet
afflux de population la ville doit
s'adapter quand les gens disent on s'est
trop développé ça génère trop de
circulation qu'en gestion c'est vrai
cette congestion circulatoire elle est
présente pour autant
c'est c'est un fait qui est assez
habituel une agglomération a tendance à
se confectionner et ce qui est
intéressant c'est pas tellement de
lutter contre la congestion pour la
supprimer mais c'est d'inventer des
politiques urbaines
pour la réguler covoiturage tramway ou
transport collectif sur la rocade ce
sont les pistes évoquées par cette
agence d'urbanisme pour les déplacements
au sein de la métropole cinquante-huit
mille familles sont encore en attente de
logements sociaux en gironde
après deux expériences déjà lancé le
conservatoire des espaces naturels de
lorraine installer une nouvelle bouée
lester au milieu du lac de gérardmer le
dispositif qui comporte 17 sonde
permettra de mesurer et d'étudier les
variations de température de l'eau à
différentes profondeurs et ce durant les
cinq prochaines années au moins une
expérience pour déterminer l'impact du
réchauffement climatique sur la
répartition de l'oxygène dans l'eau
un reportage d'art seng et d'hélène le
plat pour vosges télévision
[Musique]
il fallait bien encore quelques coups de
rame pour arriver à bon port ou plutôt
en plein milieu du lac de gérardmer car
les approximations n'était pas une
option il ya quelques jours lors du
lancement officiel d'une expérience
scientifique sur le plan d'eau un projet
matérialisé par cette bouée bien plus
sophistiqué qu'il n'y paraît on a mis un
dispositif de suivi des températures en
fait dans l'eau donc s'il s'agit d'une
bouée au dessus on a un premier câble
lester en fait qui va retenir la bouée
alors son emplacement qu'on a choisi on
a choisi de la mettre à l'emplacement
qui est le plus profond donc dans le lac
de gérardmer ses 35 mètres et sur un
autre cap qui est toujours retenu à la
bouée qui est lesté aussi on a tout
laissons les sons dont 17 dans ce lac
elles sont toutes espacées d'un maître
jusqu'à me dire 10 mètres de profondeur
et ensuite elles sont espacés tous les 4
m parce que du coup on a une variabilité
de la température à cette profondeur là
qui est moindre donc on a moins besoin
de précisions la boue et ses 17 sont
donc bien été larguée au plus profond du
lac de gérardmer cette expérience
s'inscrit dans un projet plus vaste
concernant également les lacs de retour
ne mer et longemer où les mêmes
dispositifs avaient été installés
quelques jours plus tôt un système de
mesure qui relèvera les variations de
température de l'eau pendant les cinq
prochaines années des données qui
permettront d'analyser la stratification
du lac quand on arrive à l'automne les
températures de l'air se refroidit la
température de l'eau sur la première
couche se refroidit aussi et donc ça va
densifier l'eau look est plus dense en
fait elle va devoir tendance à couler
elle va pousser les eaux du fonds vert
le dessus et du coup ça va occasionner
un mélange le mélange là il est vraiment
important pour distribuer l'oxygène mais
aussi les nutriments et ses essais sur
tout et si ça permet de rafraîchir toute
la colonne d'eau un événement naturel
biannuel essentiels à la vie aquatique
et qui est donc menacée par le
réchauffement climatique avec des
couches d'eau en surface de plus en plus
chaude le mélange pourrait ne plus
opérer au sein du lac un danger réel
déjà constaté à retourne mer ou des
universitaires de besançon avait par le
passé effectué quelques relevés si ce
mélange se fait mal ça risque
d'occasionner un pas mal de problèmes en
fait d'un lac notamment et bien une zone
au fond du lac qui pourraient se
retrouver sans oxygène donc ya pas
forcément beaucoup d'êtres vivants qui
vivent à cette strate là parce qu'il
n'ya pas les rayons lumineux qui
viennent mais on a notamment des
poissons qui passent une partie de leur
vie et du coup bah si cette zone elle
risque de grandir petit à petit on va
avoir de plus en plus on fait d'être
vivant qui va être impactée la faune
mais également la flore pourrait très
vite se retrouver menacée dans un mois
les membres du conservatoire reviendront
sur le lac afin de vérifier le bon
fonctionnement des sondes enregistreuse
une précaution qui deviendra semestriels
et permettra de commencer à étudier les
premières variations de températures qui
seront rapidement rendues publiques
cependant si les nouvelles sont
mauvaises le champ d'action sera plus
que restreint avec pour seule
possibilité de sensibiliser les
habitants à l'impact du réchauffement
climatique
vous avez sûrement remarqué cette
tendance sur vos écrans les émissions de
survie se multiplient à la télévision et
les amateurs sont nombreux à vouloir s'y
essayer
le tarn et alex andres sanches a lancé
il y a quelques années immersion break
nature il propose l'apprentissage de
techniques pour survivre en pleine
nature marie-laure le jeune et maëlys
figues et ont testé pour vous à montans
dans le tarn l'un de ces stages pendant
une journée entière regardez
première chose qu'il faut savoir pour
survivre en pleine nature faire le feu
grâce à ces pierres à feu il sera plus
facile d'allumer cette herbe sèche mais
d'autres combustibles sont encore plus
efficace comme la gale de chaîne mais
quand ça prend sans prendre il faut il
faut avoir des bons poumons là on va
voir ceux qui fument comme en province
avant de promettre comme steve
guillaume pourquoi vous êtes tous
inscrits à ce stade de survie car
c'était pour apprendre quelques
techniques basiques on est beaucoup à
bien aimé faire de la randonnée donc
c'est vrai que c'est quand même c'est
quand même sympa de savoir faire des
choses assez simples si jamais on est en
a besoin c'est très énergivores il faut
savoir être précis
savoir comment va le faire sans touré de
choses qui sont confortables se mettre à
l'abri et donc il ya toute une procédure
le bambou et surtout les corses de
bouleau sont aussi de bons combustible
qu importe la technique la patience est
nécessaire après l'entraînement c'est
maintenant l'heure d'allumer un feu en
conditions réelles sur le sol et
j'essaie de récupérer un peu des des
brindilles des boîtes différentes
tailles pour
dire les mettre au fur et à mesure que
mon feu augmente donc on va essayer
c'est aussi l'occasion de se dépenser
avec une épreuve sportive celle du
cochon pendu c'était difficile surtout
vers la fin mais en règle générale ça
fait beaucoup travaillé les avant bras
et sur les biens les exercices notamment
qu'on doit toucher l'arbre avec les deux
pieds on a vraiment la sensation d'aller
tomber de plus rare la ford pourra se
maintient sur la corde
et pour les plus téméraires alexandre
s'en fait propose des sorties en pleine
nature de trois jours dans les pyrénées
en toute autonomie
ça fait 3 cm
ils font partie des anges gardiens qui
ont veillé sur vous pendant toute votre
été les bénévoles de la société
nationale de sauvetage en mer aussi
appelée snsm reconnaissables à leur
gilet orange sont présents sur toutes
les côtes françaises et en corse
l'antenne locale est à la recherche de
bénévoles pendant les vacances d'été
bien sûr mais aussi pour l'arrière
saison très développée sur l'île de
beauté écoutez à ce propos le
responsable de l'antenne locale de
l'association nicolas lavigne nous
localement on n'a pas beaucoup de gens
de gens qui sont issus de lille
maintenant c'est pas propre à toutes les
stations snsm je pense que parce que les
situations de saisonnalité ou quelque
chose comme ça qui sont que les gens
n'ont pas le temps l'été devenir mon
fils un coup de main à l'est cnsm on
profite bien sûr on va chercher des gens
qui vont en sortir durant l'émission
pour assister les personnes en mer mais
on a aussi besoin de gens qui vont
maintenir le matériel en état que ce
soit des mécaniciens des électriciens
maintenant on commence à avoir pas mal
d'informatique sur le bateau dans même
des informaticiens ne serait utile tout
les bonhommes sont les bienvenus
une belle histoire et une passion à
présent dans cette édition jeanne 84 ans
habitante de saint malo est connu pour
son amour des fleurs tellement amoureuse
et passionnée qu'elle participe depuis
20 ans désormais au fameux concours
local des maisons fleuries son histoire
racontée par la rédaction de thé vert à
rennes
alors cette année lâcheté trois
premières se malo et troisième du
département à 84 ans jeanne est une
grande habituée ces années encore elle
participe au concours des maisons
fleuries de la ville de saint malo et
elle fait même ses vingt ans de
candidature pour moi c'est vraiment une
passion et ça m'aide dans les moments
difficiles de la vie comme tout le monde
dans notre nouvelle moi je me ressource
suis ressourcé avec mes fleurs
si la malouine participent chaque année
pour se perfectionner les fleurs c'est
avant tout pour elle le moyen de créer
du lien je fais plaisir à ma rue pas
forcément avoir humé tous les gens quand
est ce que tu fais tu mettais fleurs on
me le demande parce que des gens y
viennent prennent des photos des petits
conseils aussi que les gens participent
adéquat au nom dans le giro avec des
fleurs comme jeanne 78 autres malouins
ont participé au traditionnel concours
en 2019 balcons fenêtres et jardins
fleuris visibles depuis la rue peuvent
donc candidate et et ce depuis 40 ans
mais cette année le rendez-vous connaît
quelques changements avec la mise en
avant de la biodiversité il ya une vraie
prise de conscience et on veut que les
malouins soit vraiment acteur de
l'embellissement de la ville mais
également de la restauration de la
biodiversité en ville s'agit vraiment de
mettre la nature en ville de développer
toutes les plantes mellifères par
exemple la bourrache la vipérine
la phacélie
allez partons dans la loi maintenant
pour faire connaissance d'un drôle de
collectionneurs aussi paul robert
retraité collectionne lui les briques il
en conserve plus de mille dans un musée
dédié à champdieu une véritable passion
un désir de sauvegarder aussi un
savoir-faire les briqueteries a suffi de
morgane grosse pour tl7 la télévison de
la loire
bienvenue au musée de la brique vous
êtes ici dans les cuisines du prieuré
bénédictin de chandieu qui a été investi
par les bric il ya une trentaine
d'années c'est un endroit rare en france
un lieu exclusivement dédié aux briques
en argile à ce jour environ mille
briques sont répertoriés et classés dans
ses pièces du prieuré de chandieu les
briques qui sont là sont des briques de
construction qui servait à tous les
usages des bâtiments pub des bâtiments
publics ou privés paul robert les a
rongé par pays ou par région d'origine
tout estampillé du nom de l' usine où
elles ont été fabriquées cette passion
pour les bric est née un peu par hasard
l'idée de collectionner les briques de
lait au départ c'était pas une
collection ça a été un ramassis de
briques parce que j'ai trouvé que c'est
à des choses superbes et c'est alors
qu'il tombe sur une brique marqué et
commence alors son investigation elle
était marqué la corée chandieu jeudi de
l'accord et oui chez uob à champdieu
briqueterie j'sais pas on a trouvé la
briqueterie ou ceux où se faisaient les
brics un rat qui sont ici un champ du
alors je voulais en savoir plus je suis
allé sur le site et on a découvert un
lieu passionnant de cette trouvaille
paul robert poursuit ses recherches au
gré de ses promenades et de ses voyages
il rapporte des briques de presque tous
les départements de france mais aussi de
l'étranger
je les volets dans une distillerie de
whisky en irlande bon alors qu'elle
était c'était sur un lieu en démolition
tout le monde avait acheté du whisky ben
moi j'ai piqué j'avais volé une brique
en 1900 ce sont près de 200 briqueterie
qui sont en activité dans le département
de la loire en bon collectionneur paul
robert
même créé ce nuancier de briques selon
la composition de l'argile nom se situe
à peu près par là notre région des paris
c'est sa science ça c'est du saint paul
de vence grasse c'est la briqueterie
régional juan grâce au musée le
collectionneur veut sauvegarder un
savoir-faire imbattable sur le sujet ce
ligérien c'est tout au long de ces
années documenter sur cet artisanat
lycée oui la terre était écrasée ici les
séchoirs la mise en forme la terre elle
est fou ça c'était ce qui représentait à
peu près une briqueterie de l'époque
toujours une briqueterie artisanale où
il y avait très peu de
très peu de personnel trois ou quatre
adultes maximum 3 3 ou 4 oui beaucoup
plus d'enfants aujourd'hui son musée est
voué à déménager certes avec un peu
d'amertume mais ce qu'il espère c'est
que ces briques puisse continuer à
raconter des histoires aux visiteurs qui
franchissent la porte
à limoges l'histoire s'est créé dans les
pas du pèlerinage vers saint jacques de
compostelle la capitale de la porcelaine
vient de créer un itinéraire bis pour
les pèlerins grâce à ce nouveau chemin
ils auront désormais le choix entre le
tracé historique et le nouveau qui leur
permettra d'emprunter un circuit plus
accessible et plus paisible le long de
la vienne ils pourront aussi découvrir
les coquilles saint-jacques fabriqué en
porcelaine de limoges les précisions
avec alain dru au de la rédaction de
cette es libre sur place
près de 2000 pèlerins traversent limoges
sur le chemin de compostelle
jusqu'à aujourd'hui un itinéraire passé
par la ville désormais un itinéraire bis
est proposée le long de la vie est notre
fierté du charme de la vienne
voilà pour peut-être pour certains
pèlerins éviter de monter en
centre-ville parce qu'ils sont pas
forcément intéressés par le patrimoine
voilà ils sont pressés et donc
l'itinéraire bis séné terreur plutôt
bucolique voilà qui nous permet de
profiter des bords de vienne a validé en
fait c'est de profiter de ce chemin de
saint jacques de compostelle pour
renforcer l'effet bords de vienne que
l'on à un stylet avec avec émile roger
lamberti au niveau de la municipalité
l'aménagement des bords de vienne
aujourd'hui eh bien ils avancent ils se
hissent se développe et les chemins
jacquaires font partie finalement de cet
univers supplémentaires aujourd'hui on
avait un itinéraire pire ordinaire
classiques historiques et qui
traversaient le pont saint etienne eh
bien demain il ya un hic les abysses qui
lui va longer les bords de vienne eh
bien il participera pleinement à
l'attractivité bien sûr des pèlerins
dont des extérieurs mais aussi des
limougeaudes et des limougeaudes le
nouvel itinéraire est balisé par des
coquilles en porcelaine aux couleurs des
chemins de saint jacques les couleurs
de compostelle
penser ce qu'ils étaient à peu près
prévu lui semble au niveau couleur et
ce soit le bleu ou le rouge jaune une
couleur qui est obtenu à haute
température
comme comme le bleu toujours dire on est
on est dans la même lignée que le bleu
pour 20 go qui vont servir de repère aux
pèlerins leur poser le résultat d'un
long travail de préparation
soumis à de multiples autorisations faut
des autorisations spéciales surtout sur
un site comme celui ci pour
saint-etienne qui est un monument
historique évidemment classés par
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
donc avec des recommandations et des
prescriptions très précisément et en
présence de la pause la première co qui
s'est deux ans travaille avec
l'élaboration du dossier le choix du
prestataire la définition du sujet les
financements les autorisations diverses
effectivement les liens avec
l'association des une chemin de saint
jacques de compostelle avec qui on a
validé settini et une erreur bis et
surtout dans le cadre de limoges qui est
une ville créative de l'unesco et pour
mettre enfin en valeur le patrimoine de
céramistes porcelaine de notre belle
ville
[Musique]
en martinique maintenant une association
crée des décors naturels ont valorisé
les sites touristiques de l'île annie
géant sur un rocher une balançoire dans
l'eau turquoise autant de spots qui sont
devenus très vite viraux sur les réseaux
sociaux johan boulard pour via tv sur
place
dernière vérification avant que les
visiteurs ne prennent place sécurité
oblige quand j'ai vu la vie ce qui déjà
situés tout est toujours bien sûr et en
fait les nus et de poivrons à la hauteur
c'est souvent avec le poids ça descend
l'opération est hebdomadaire depuis la
mise en place de cette structure
objectif valoriser certains spots
parfois méconnue on habite une région
touristique
alors j'ai arrêté mais c'est vrai que
personne n'a eu à lutter jusqu'à présent
de personnes sur la plage de
saint-georges-de-didonne qui très belle
l'édifice une balançoire les pieds dans
l'eau réalisé en pin traité et mesurant
1 6 m sur 4 entièrement financés par
leurs propres deniers la première des
compétences je dis que c'est la volonté
ensuite il faut également voir de la
disponibilité puisque nous sommes pas du
métier on a tous une profession à côté
et dépenseront n'essaie pas tous mais on
a un point commun qui était qui et
puisse donc c'est lui qui a initié le
projet nous nous sommes rencontrés on a
quand même remarquer qu on partage les
mêmes valeurs donc oui on est la
martinique
depuis les membres de l'association
valorisation martinique ne se sont plus
quittés plus au sud cette annonce michel
que nous marquerons une nouvelle étape
de maintenance
et comme le dit le dicton petit à petit
l'oiseau fait son nid à l'oni hall avait
vu déjà en photo et sur une rivière vers
une libye en cascade et on a trouvé en
fait que c'était un super spot pour
faire des photos et donc du coup à
partir de là on a commencé à dessiner
les plans on a fait une réunion l'idée
séduit sur la toile les internautes se
passent le mot est aujourd'hui il faut
avoir sa photo sur l'un des sites si je
suis beaucoup connectés donc du coup
j'ai vu ce spot photos ici j'ai déjà été
à l'hostellerie temps où la balançoire
donc au big up à valorisation martinique
et je suis abonnée donc du coup je suis
voilà ces jeunes ne s'arrêteront pas là
et espère un rayonnement international
dans le nord des sites ont d'ores et
déjà été identifiées
reste à passer à la phase de réalisation
ils veulent cependant resté discret
quand on lui et à la forme de leur
prochaine création
heureusement les artistes et le public
ont repris le chemin des spectacles et
des festivals cet été c'est le cas du
festival d'humour de monte carlo les
sérénissimes et cette année le festival
s'est délocalisé une nouvelle fois à
valberg la célèbre station de l'arrière
pays de la côte d'azur et cette fois ci
en extérieur vous allez le voir six
humoristes dont selig denis maréchal ou
vanessa caillot se sont produits devant
le cadre majestueux du lac du sénateur
les spectacles en plein air le vent en
poupe par ces périodes de co vide comme
nous l'expliquent le président du
conseil départemental des
alpes-maritimes charles ange ginésy au
micro de christophe rigaud
je pense que c'est important c'est ce
que nous a menés aussi la crise
sanitaire la pandémie la crise qu vide
qui nous a fait découvrir que tout
pouvait se produire à l'extérieur y
compris dans des conditions hivernales
on re découvre le contact avec la nature
c'est un grand moment c'est un moment le
mélezin qui verdoie autour de nous est
aujourd'hui un cadre exceptionnel donc
effectivement être un extérieur c'est un
bon moment pour les humoristes aussi
une idée de sortie si vous êtes en
bretagne à présent le musée de farouette
dans le morbihan a lancé il ya quelques
semaines sa nouvelle exposition son nom
le paysan breton dans la peinture
décryptage avec karine chevalier pour la
chaîne tébéo et la chaîne tv sud les
chaînes du groupe le télégramme en
bretagne
[Musique]
des visages marqués par les éléments des
sommes façonnés par le dur labeur dès le
début du 19e siècle les peintres et
dessinateurs trouve plusieurs
inspirations dans le paysan breton un
petit peu effarouchés méfiants et
surtout il y avait l'aspect
vestimentaire qui était intéressant par
son pittoresque et puis le fait que les
hommes au 19e siècle portait encore pour
certains les cheveux longs des scènes au
fil des saisons dans les champs et à la
ferme des rassemblements festifs et
religieux mais aussi des moments plus
intimistes révélée par certains artistes
certains se sont installés en bretagne
et sont devenus les voisins de paysans
et donc ils sont été bien intégré au
prêt donc de ces populations
ils ont sympathisé si bien qu'ils ont pu
pénétrer aussi dans leur intérieur et
les représenter vivre sereinement vallat
auprès de leur famille et dans des
périodes de repos également la dureté du
travail occupe ici une place
prépondérante peuvent re représentative
de ce mont paysans cette peinture de
paul sérusier des t2 1920 on voit sur
cette peinture des mouvements des
courbes très intéressante que sérusier
fait épouse également aux fourches et de
foin et que ses hommes portent avec
difficulté on sent le travail la
pénibilité du labeur 160 oeuvres
retracent ainsi l'évolution de
l'agriculture du 19e ou 20e siècle mais
une réflexion s'ouvre également sur des
valeurs telles que la terre est le
retour à la terre l'évolution des
pratiques que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
et si nous prenions un bon bol d'air
frais maintenant pour terminer ce
journal sur les bords du lac léman la
réputation du village d'ivoire n'est
plus à faire la cité médiévale regorge
de trésors comme le jardin des cinq sens
un jardin unique et enivrant victoria
lopez a visité pour nous ce havre de
paix et de couleurs un reportage de huit
mont-blanc sur place
derrière ces portes se cachant jardin
secret imaginé par la famille bouvier
d'ivoire il invite les visiteurs à le
contempler depuis plus de 30 ans dans
les 2500 m² de jardin mille cinq cents
variétés de plantes dévoilent leurs
couleurs leurs odeurs et leur curiosité
à l'image de la scabreuse ping pong on
s'aperçoit que ça ressemble aussi à un
volant de badminton vraiment pourquoi
parce que la plante elle sait très bien
comment marche la nature on a une graine
ici assez lourde qui va permettre aux
poids d'amener la graine vers le bas
pour qu'elles se plante directement dans
la terre
le petit volant pour partir le plus loin
possible au vent le carré des plantes
médicinales abrite lui des variétés aux
différentes vertus certaines seraient
même magique le mot non de ragots
rappel harry potter et il y à bien des
histoires derrière elle parce que même
sur des enluminures du moyen-age on voit
la représentation de cette plante cette
fameuse mans de raccord avec un corps à
la place de la racine et on voit des
paysans vouloir l'arraché mais pas être
bien rassuré du coup il va tâcher un
chien autour de la plante ils nous
proposaient le repas du chien un peu
plus loin pour que le chien tir et
arrache la plante parce que tout le
monde était persuadé que cette plante
sur l'arrachaient elle criait et jeté
des mauvais sorts à côté de la
mandragore l'abri ionia également appelé
n'avait du diable ou la digital des
plantes aux bienfaits certains mais qui
s'avère toxique si on les touche où les
ingère sans l'intermédiaire d'une
transformation par les laborantins non
loin de là la rose d'ivoire qui fête son
premier anniversaire se laisse caresser
des yeux et du bout des doigts
voilà de bien belles images pour
conclure cette édition du grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales et
sur tv5 monde on se retrouve pour une
prochaine édition est un tour complet de
l'actualité estivale des territoires au
revoir à tous
[Musique]